okay
okay
so
cartels
so we've got
all
um
thank you
thank you
for me
okay
stays here in texas
we squeaked it out
i've got the steaks they're marinated
sorry i have a wife at nebraska
uh
mhm
[Music]
up over there
um
oh
did you lost
already
um
fish
thank you everybody for gathering with
us today we're here today to talk about
something that
more than half
of the governors of the united states of
america have been working on that we
want to announce to you today
before we start talking about that
however
i do want to
talk a little bit about
something that happened as i was
traveling to the rio grande valley today
there was a shooting that took place in
high school
located in arlington texas
i've had the opportunity to talk to the
mayor in arlington texas and to
talk to director steve mccraw the
director of texas department of public
safety
to make sure that the state of texas
is using the texas department of public
safety as well as any and all other
tools
to assist
arlington and the surrounding
communities all of which have law
enforcement fully engaged in this
process
let me just give you the latest update
that i have right now
knowing that facts are changing on the
ground as we speak
according to director mccraw the school
is safe and secure
the shooter has been identified and
there is a search for the shooter
we know the shooter's car
we feel confident that the shooter will
be located very very soon
the shooter
under texas law
it is illegal
for the shooter to either possess or to
have purchased the gun that was used
in this crime
what i understand just very briefly
is that a fight broke out inside the
school and the shooter pulled out the
gun that he had illegally
and shot several people
we are still awaiting word about exactly
how many people were shot i don't have
any information
about any loss of life but it would be
completely premature
to make any comment whatsoever about the
lives of anyone
what we can say of obviously is this
and that is we grieve for everyone
who's been harmed or impacted by this in
any way whatsoever
and
we as a state working with the local
communities will do everything possible
to ensure
that the shooter
is swiftly and effectively prosecuted
now on to
what we what we are here for today
obviously we are
at the border here in texas
and we're here to talk about
border related issues
and let me just start out by making a
very clear point
and that is president joe biden has
caused a humanitarian crisis and chaos
on our border
all americans saw exactly what happened
in del rio texas just last month and we
know
that that chaos
will be repeated unless and until
president biden takes action
26 of america's governors have worked
together to develop specific
actions that biden can take immediately
to end the crisis on the border that he
has caused
we all of us asked the president for
meaning to visit with us about this
and he refused
to meet with us and he completely
ignored us
nine
of the 26 governors that crafted this
action plan
gathered today at the border a border by
the way
that president biden has never even been
to
we're here to announce 10 actions
that president biden must take
immediately
for me i will mention three
one
the byte administration must reinstate
the remain and mexico protocols which
require asylum seekers to remain in
mexico while awaiting their court
hearing
this is a proven deterrent to crossing
illegally
second
the binding administration must finish
securing the border which includes among
other things
finishing the border wall
third divine administration must enforce
title 42 health restrictions at the
border
and then i'll add this
while joe biden has done absolutely
nothing
to solve the crisis that he caused
texas
has taken 10 actions
not plans but actions
to address
the biden border crisis
one i signed laws providing three
billion dollars of texas taxpayer money
for texas to do the federal government's
job to secure the border
second
i've deployed thousands of national
guard and texas department of public
safety troopers and officers to secure
the border
they are credited with forming a barrier
that shut down the illegal migration
surge in del rio
third
we created a system to arrest and jail
illegal immigrants who are trespassing
in texas
fourth
i signed a budget approval and provided
the authorization
to build a border wall in texas
fifth
i signed a law to make it easier to
prosecute smugglers who are bringing
illegal immigrants into texas
sixth
i signed nine laws cracking down on
human trafficking in texas
seven
i signed a law that creates a new crime
for the manufacturer or distribution of
fentanyl
this targets the gangs and cartels that
biden is allowing into america who are
trafficking this deadly drug
eight
i declared a disaster for border
counties that are suffering from the
surge of illegal border crossings
nine
i issued an executive order to prevent
ngos from transporting illegal
immigrants in texas
and tenth
texas took legal action
to enforce
the remain in mexico policy as well as
the title of 42 policy
in that regard a federal judge in texas
ruled in our favor
commanding the bite administration to
continue to keep the remain and mexico
policy in place
the byte administration has refused not
only to keep that policy in place but
the byte administration has also ignored
that order issued by a federal court
that was appealed all the way up to the
supreme court and allowed to stay in
place at this time
the body administration
is in violation of a federal court order
to impose the remain in mexico policy
last want to make clear
that while biden continues to dither
texas and other states
are taking action to do the federal
government's job
i think the governors from across
america who have sent resources to our
state
they understand the magnitude of the
problem as well as the need for action
and i think the governors who were able
to adjust their schedules
to be with us here today
there are several other speakers
including first the director of the
texas department of public safety steve
mccraw
thank you governor
i were to say this before you've heard
the governor say it
there cannot be
the most significant threat to texas
is clearly an unsecured international
border with mexico it's the most
significant public safety and homeland
security threat it's allowed mexican
cartels to evolve and become the most
dangerous
most violent most brutal
criminal organizations in the world they
dominate the drug and human trafficking
market throughout the united states
and if you have a fentanyl problem in
iowa you have one
in oklahoma
you have one you have a border problem
that's exactly what's been going on the
governor has taken us the state spending
a lot of money over the years in terms
of how we can provide direct support to
the brave men and women of the u.s
border patrol to be able to support
their mission
what the governor's done now though is
taking us from a reactive position and
put us in a proactive position and
prevent a position
so
no more in terms of detection
interdiction okay and seizure and
apprehension the focus is prevention
from the start and leaning forward in
that regard to that end he's formulated
a plan that has all the border basics
including infrastructure personnel
capabilities technology and doctrine
that can secure the texas-mexico border
and unfortunately uh the state of texas
has made it very clear the governor made
it very clear we can't wait for
washington to do it
we don't need their permission to
protect texas there's a bottom line and
we're forced you know we're blessed the
fact that
the government leaned forward on this
particular issue and governor thank you
on behalf of the men and women
department of public safety the state of
texas for all you do for public safety
and for those people in the law
enforcement profession means a lot that
you care and so does the state
legislature and i know these governors
feel the same way and so very proud to
stand with you today and thank you for
all you do and thank you for sending
troopers down here and resources we
appreciate that we know that by putting
them here we've been able to protect
your state and i know you care deeply
about protecting your citizens from harm
and god bless you and governor that's
all my remarks thank you
next we have brandon judd the president
of the border patrol council
good afternoon thank you governor
greatly appreciate it governors thank
you
thank you i i can tell you that law
enforcement greatly appreciates um the
work these men and women are doing
sure would have been nice
if we could have just as many democrat
governors as well
to discuss this issue we have to have an
honest conversation criminal cartels
listen to actions they don't care about
words
and the actions of the biden
administration is very clear if you
cross the border illegally you will be
rewarded and that's what this
administration is doing
so as they give lip service to an issue
as they say the borders are closed their
actions clearly should demonstrate
otherwise if we continue to reward
criminality if we continue to reward
people for crossing the borders
illegally people are going to continue
to come
it's interesting we always say we
shouldn't recreate the will
president biden has the blueprints
president trump did in fact create the
will he showed what needs to be done in
order to control illegal immigration if
we can control illegal immigration we
can then go after the profits
of the cartels we can cut down on the
drugs that are going to these states
that are killing so many of our children
of our family members
if we can't do that the cartels will
continue to control everything that is
happening on the border president biden
has a responsibility
to the citizens of this great nation
to do what's right by them
not by the cartels do not allow the
cartels to make the profits that they
are making which by the way
is over 400 million dollars every month
in illegal alien smuggling that does not
count the drug smuggling
over 400 million dollars a month
that's an astronomical number there's a
reason that they're in that business in
illegal business again i want to thank
the governors
i feel for you i feel for what you have
to deal with in your states
with your families with your family
members
simply because we don't have the
policies policies that does not cost the
taxpayer
a cent
if you ask me
do we need more resources we do do we
need more infrastructure yes technology
yes but it must start with policy
policy will allow us to get this under
control and then we can look at what
needs to be done after that
governor abbott's uh leadership on this
issue has been fantastic law enforcement
is grateful to him for what he's been
doing to help us try to get this issue
under control but without president
biden we're going to continue to talk
about this year in year out thank you
governor thank you
next is arizona governor doug ducey
thanks very much brandon and i want to
say thank you to governor abbott for
welcoming us to see what's unfolding
here in texas the situation here is
certainly outrageous and i want you to
know you've seen the coverage men on
horseback literally hurting men and
women thousands of migrants gathered in
a bidenville under del rio bridge
children abandoned on the treacherous
journey to our country
it's a tragedy and i can tell you the
border situation is just as out of
control in the state of arizona
the border sector in yuma has had more
than a one thousand percent increase in
apprehensions compared to last year
the highest increase among all sectors
the tucson sector has seen more than a
200 percent increase in apprehensions
and it's not just the people that are
crossing the border it's the lethal
drugs almost 2 000 pounds of fentanyl
and over 13 000 pounds of
methamphetamine have been seized in
arizona sectors alone
this year
just think about how many drugs are
slipping through the cracks and slipping
into the bloodstreams in our communities
this isn't a figure of speech this is
our reality
fentanyl overdoses have replaced car
accidents as the leading cause of death
for people 19 and younger in pima county
one of our border communities
pima county deputy sheriffs are
responding to a call involving fentanyl
every 40 hours
by neglecting the border president biden
has fueled an opioid epidemic in america
the biden border crisis has also led to
a disturbing rise in crime in our
streets
because our border sheriffs have to
spread their personnel thin
between the border and the rest of their
counties there are far fewer officers
patrolling our streets and keeping
arizonans safe
in yuma the amount of theft has
increased by over 36 percent compared to
the second half of last year
homicides in tucson are up almost 60
percent compared to this time last year
our law enforcement officers in arizona
are some of the best in the nation but
they can only do so much when hundreds
of thousands of migrants are flooding
into the country illegally every month
there are three people to blame for
making america a more dangerous place
president joe biden
vice president kamala harris and
secretary alejandro mayorkas
it's no secret anymore they have created
this crisis
and americans know it
this year president biden took the oath
of office to become our country's 46th
commander-in-chief
instead of commanding our military
he's commanded drug cartels and other
criminals to wreak havoc on the united
states
he and vice president harris and
secretary mayorkus have allowed
criminals and drugs to run rampant in
our streets and it's time for them to do
something about it
i've joined twenty five other governors
many who are standing behind me today in
sending a letter to president biden
requesting a meeting now
either he's unwilling to solve this
crisis or he doesn't know how
so we're here to offer solutions
it's been 16 days since we sent the
president the letter and we still
haven't heard anything back
we're not going to sit around while joe
biden refuses to act
the white house press secretary last
week told the republican governors to be
a part of the
solution we've tried to meet with the
president and be a part of the solution
but he refuses
even worse
he ignores
just like he's ignoring the border and
the well-being of the american people if
the president won't meet with us then
we'll share our policy ideas today
hopefully he'll hear the solutions and
act
the biden administration should begin by
dedicating federal resources needed to
eradicate human trafficking and drug
trafficking along the southern border
we need additional resources to fight
drug cartels arrest offenders support
victims and prevent lethal and dangerous
drugs from reaching american cities and
schools across our country
the drug enforcement administration
issued a public safety warning for the
first time in six years as international
and domestic traffickers flood the u.s
with fake prescriptions laced with
lethal doses of fentanyl
americans lives are at risk
we need this administration to provide
adequate resources to stop the flow of
these deadly drugs across the border
the border must be secured and criminals
must be deported
on top of that the u.s should re-enter
all agreements with our northern
triangle partners including mexico
upon taking office president biden
issued an ill-advised and frankly
foolish executive order that terminated
agreements with el salvador guatemala
honduras and mexico
those countries had already agreed to
enforce their respective borders fix
their asylum systems and receive
migrants seeking asylum before they
journey north to the united states
upon joe biden's open borders invitation
and our final solution is about
communication
president biden
vice president harris and biden
administration officials at every level
of government need to speak with a
unified and clear voice to potential
migrants
our country's borders are not open
and abuse or misuse of the asylum system
will not be tolerated
this isn't hard or at least it shouldn't
be but we are talking about the biden
administration after all
we can turn things around
we can keep drugs
out of our communities and our schools
and we can make our streets safer
we can have an immigration policy that
doesn't include men on horseback hurting
migrants
president biden this is up to you are
you willing to make the changes
necessary to keep americans and these
migrants out of harm's way that's the
question you need to answer
thank you thank you governor
and uh next is iowa governor kim
reynolds thank you governor it's a
pleasure to be here you know over the
past eight months we have seen illegal
immigration
just soar and in fact it's becoming a a
migration and joe biden has done
absolutely nothing to confront this
self-inflicted crisis
as chief executives of our state
republican governors have come together
to discuss what we expect the federal
government to take action on so that we
can stop
the crisis and humanitarian crisis
that's happening at this border um you
know
the security and we have seen um
we need joe biden to step up and lead we
can do this by enacting common sense uh
policies that will reduce
never-ending programs uh but his
policies have done just the exact
opposite what we're seeing coming out of
the biden administration is
incentivizing
actual uh migration and illegal
crossings is at a 20-year high including
the crossings of unaccompanied children
and what they're doing after that is
they're secretly transporting them into
our states across this country and iowa
is one of those states in april we had
15 unaccompanied minor girls that were
flown into the des moines airport in the
middle of the night and then they were
boarded on charter buses and after we
were made aware of this happening in the
state of iowa we reached out to the
biden administration
to ask them if they were responsible for
this action taking place and for over a
month they denied any involvement in
this action and so we were concerned
that it could be human trafficking and
so we used our own resources to continue
to investigate the plane that had 19
young women being dropped off in the
state of iowa and moved to charter buses
after weeks of denying that they had no
involvement in it whatsoever they
finally admitted that it was their
administration that was responsible
for that plane landing in the state of
iowa i can tell you tennessee has a
similar story as well as iowa so if this
is happening in iowa and if it's
happening in tennessee this is happening
in states all across our country and at
a minimum this administration should not
only provide transparency but they
should notify governors across this
country when illegal migrants and
unaccompanied children are being dropped
off in our state because then we become
responsible for them so that is a policy
solution that he could could enact uh
tomorrow in addition to that he should
require the office of refugee
resettlement to enforce that policy
action in addition to that they need to
re resume the deportation of all
convicted criminals when president biden
took office the first thing he did was
to issue an executive order that ordered
ice to do limited deportations that is
unacceptable that should have never
happened all convicted
illegal criminals need to be deported
and that is another thing that he could
do tomorrow
thank you governor
and next we have nebraska governor pete
ricketts
thank you very much governor abbott for
hosting us here today and i want to
start by thanking the men and women of
the customs and border patrol they are
heroes helping to secure our nation's
border here and they need to be
supported so thank you today
[Applause]
i also want to thank all the national
guard and law enforcement folks who are
also doing the same so can we give them
a round of applause too
[Applause]
president biden thinks that he can
ignore this humanitarian and security
crisis and it will go away
but we are here today to shine a light
on what is going on here at the southern
border and how it is impacting all of
our states not just the state of texas
and that's why we put forward this
10-point plan that governor abbott
kicked off for us and my colleagues
other colleagues had highlighted i'm
going to round out a couple more of the
points that we're asking for as part of
this overall plan that we know will work
to help us stem this mass migration into
our country
one of the things the bite
administration must do is end the catch
and release program
this was an obama-era program
that was terminated under the trump
administration and restarted again under
the bind administration
what this does is just incentivize
people to come across the border
illegally
because they are then released
and that is creating a crisis not only
here at the border but health hazards
across our country
so if you think about what's going on
here
as reports have shown 18
of the families that are coming here
illegal and being released
are testing positive for coronavirus
covet 19.
and when it comes to the unaccompanied
miners that's 20 percent
in fact i think there's a report out
there that shows that the buying
administration may have placed up to 40
000 covent positive
people into our cities here in the
united states
what the buying administration needs to
do
is stop this policy
and then resource the judicial system to
be able to expedite these cases
there are is a record over a million
people that are waiting to get
their cases hurt as we heard earlier
today from brandon judd in our briefing
this can take two years
before their court case comes back up
again
and that's if they show back up
so the bind administration must take
steps to end this catch and release
program
and then also the bind administration
must properly resource this border
that means they need to resource
more for customers and border patrol and
the national guard now look folks this
is not new four previous administrations
have deployed national guard troops to
the border to be able to help out with
this crisis down here
the blind administration needs to call
it more soldiers to be able to do that
they can do that under title 10
so that the states don't bear the cost
that's what the proper role the federal
government is
but because they have failed to properly
resource this border
states like nebraska have stepped up
earlier this summer we provided the
state of texas with some of our state
troopers to be able to come out and help
out with some of the law enforcement and
let me tell you folks the stories are
just heart-wrenching
when i was talking to captain jason
scott who led our mission he was talking
about how
most the people they encountered coming
across the border illegally surrendered
to them
because of the dire conditions they were
in they wanted the help
he talked about a two-year-old who had
been in the desert for two weeks with no
food
this is the humanitarian crisis that is
going on right here in the state of
texas
the president must act he cannot
continue to ignore this humanitarian and
security crisis any longer
and it he has seen
that we the states have a ten point plan
that will address us and we know as
brandon judy was talking about earlier
it will work because it's worked before
we're calling on the president to act to
end this crisis thank you
thank you
also i want to let you know also joining
with us here today
is the governor from oklahoma kevin
stitt the governor from ohio
dewine
the governor from georgia governor kemp
the idaho governor brad little montana
governor greg giamforte and the wyoming
governor mark jordan and we have with us
uh the texas as united general tracy
norris as well as the national guard
general in charge of border security and
that is general euless with that we'll
take a few questions
the american people saw
the crisis at the border
when they saw the way the dubai
administration
allowed del rio to be overrun
the governors
insist
the dubai administration reinstate the
effective plans that were put in place
by president trump
and the governors also are adamant
that while president biden
may be silent about this and may not be
taking any action whatsoever we are
going to act
in his absence
our constituents demand it not just here
in texas but i can speak for all of
these other governors here when all of
their states are suffering because of
the massive inflow of fentanyl into the
united states which is leading to deaths
in all of our states this is one of if
not the most urgent matter that we're
facing in the united states at this time
and it's time for the blind
administration to wake up and get on the
job and do its job to protect the
sovereignty and safety of the united
states of america
governor kai also stepping on that one
to say this is not a crisis to ignore
the data
through august customs and border patrol
has had over 1.3 million contacts
through august of last year that number
was 272 thousand nearly five times as
many contacts this year that's why this
is not about illegal immigration this is
about a mass migration
and if you look at april 2021
ice
completed
2962 removals that is the lowest number
on record so while we are seeing a surge
at the southern border the bind
administration is not resourcing our
agencies properly to be able to take the
appropriate law enforcement action
that is why the president must act
governor critics say that the operation
is unconstitutional how do you respond
to that
we think that
the person who is acting inconsistent
with the constitution
is the president of the united states
he's completely abdicated his
constitutional duties and that is why it
is necessary for the states to take
action we believe the states are
authorized by the united states
constitution to do exactly what texas is
doing under the 10-point plan that we
are already acting on right now our job
is to secure the health and safety and
security of our constituents and if joe
biden's not going to do it the governors
of the united states of america will do
it governor secretary
stated earlier today that the federal
government was now ready to handle a
crisis similar to what we saw in the rio
are you concerned are you can you trust
in what the federal government is saying
to see a scenario like we saw in another
area in the world
i cannot count the number of
misrepresentations that have been made
by secretary mayorkas he has
continuously misled the american public
including even saying that the border is
closed and secure which could be
nothing further from the truth
i believe congress
should investigate and call upon the
resignation of secretary mayorkas for
abandoning his job not doing what the
secretary of homeland security is
supposed to do which among other things
means supporting and deploying
uh border patrol which are completely
lacking and inadequate down here and so
secretary marcus
is a disaster in what he's done and no
one should put any trust or confidence
in anything that he says
governor governor closing ports
there are no
new policies programs or operations that
have been implemented since del rio we
are not prepared to handle anything
we're not prepared to handle the numbers
that are coming up we're not prepared to
handle the 60 000 that peru just
reported is coming through their borders
no policies programs or operations
that's the answer to your question and
one other point on that one other point
on that every policy that we sent to the
president he can handle with the stroke
of a pen he does not need the help of
congress secretary mayorkas has been
non-responsive to we as border governors
and we have 26
governors on that letter asking for
action right now secretary mayorkas took
90 days to respond to the letter arizona
sent him in march he should resign
vice president harris has been the worst
possible choice to be the borders are
she's never shown any care about this
issue or any level of seriousness and
joe biden has never even been to the
border but we are here today presenting
solutions we will work with them this is
a crisis and it requires action with
urgency
we will take any and all action that
needs to be taken
understand this however uh and and that
is most if not all
of the illegal immigration that is
occurring
is between the ports of entry uh that is
why we are having surge resources
between the points of entry uh because
our job is to uh our focal point is to
try to reduce people who are crossing
here illegally
in mexico you mentioned
with spectrum news one
uh on your order to arrest migrants that
were crossing because of trans
i spoke to several of them and they got
their documents the release documents
just like anybody else how effective do
you think it is
in the light of that and also
mpp have you considered that mexico has
not yet agreed
so with regard to the remaining mexico
policy there is a court order requiring
the obama administration uh to work with
mexico to reimplement that policy
something that the bite administration
is refusing to do
second with regard to the texas policy
to arrest in jail people who are illegal
immigrants coming into texas and
trespassing on private property
that's an effective way of sending a
message that if you come into the state
of texas illegally you have a high
likelihood of not getting caught and
released but instead arrested in jail
governor connection between fentanyl
here at the border in far away states
like iowa or perhaps ohio
earlier today
director mccraw
showed all of these governors a map
of the way that fentanyl crisscrosses
the entire united states of america
all of the governors who are with us
today and those who are not with us
today
that have fentanyl going into their
states to give you just one mathematical
example and that is
just the amount of fentanyl apprehended
just by the texas department of public
safety just this year
is more than enough to kill every man
woman and child in the states of texas
california and new york
all of those states are subject to
having fentanyl taken into the states
and we'll have governor dewine from ohio
tell you more about what's happening in
history
sure
so in ohio at least 80 percent of our
overdose deaths every week are caused by
fentanyl
it is being mixed into everything
i get
calls i get letters uh from family
members who have lost someone so this
crisis at the southern border is a
humanitarian crisis
it's also a drug crisis uh it's a
fentanyl crisis
and we're seeing the same thing as i've
indicated at our press conferences with
interstate 35 and interstate 80 we're a
direct route for drugs to pipe through
des moines council bluffs and then out
through the united states we've seen a
tremendous increase four times uh meth
as well as fentanyl has increased
earlier this year it was a thousand
percent increase from what we saw over
the same time last year and that's
killing our young people and the other
thing that we're also experiencing is
the purity of the fentanyl that's coming
in and the way that they're lacing it
we've also seen a tremendous uptick in
the use of uh naloxone naloxone um
to combat fentanyl and so we are seeing
it like every other state across this
country and it's taxing not only uh
iowans but our law enforcement as well
could you explain exactly i can just
jump on there with uh nebraska as well
say
same thing is happening in nebraska so
talking to the
colonel by state patrol methamphetamine
in the midwest is up four times what it
was last year
and we have seen that our state patrol
has confiscated more than about two and
a half times the amount of fentanyl in
our state this year versus last year so
we're seeing the same thing as far as
the impact on our communities with
regards to drugs governor governor we've
seen you down here several times the
governor's on today exactly where you
went do they
were they on the river did they visit
with any migrant arrested centers could
you explain where you took them sure
before coming here we had a briefing
at the texas department of public safety
headquarters where uh brandon judge and
brendan judd and director mccraw
explained to them exactly what was
taking place on the border where it was
taken place and what the consequences
were for all of the states it will be
after this uh that the governors are
going to be able to visit different
locations some by boat some by air some
on ground
governor several
been formally times of a crime
what's your reaction on that
uh if you're talking about in the arrest
of jail programs
yeah and so the the prosecuting
attorneys in those counties have the
legal responsibility
to effectively charge anybody who's
arrested for a crime we urge them to
charge them with the highest potential
penalty that they can be charged with to
make sure that they remain in jail for
as long as possible two more questions
at the border several times with
president donald former president donald
trump with ted cruz now if the blind
administration doesn't respond to this
how do you and other people plan to move
forward
we we will
speaking for the state of texas we are
going to continue to escalate what we
are doing to respond to this crisis
we hear
stories about the potential for oncoming
caravans and as we're gathering here
today
the national guard and the texas
department of public safety are getting
ready to be able to respond to those
caravans in ways that secure texas
last question
governor are you concerned that the new
law of constitutional carry is sending
the wrong message to young people
so very importantly
with regard to the school shooting that
took place today as well as with
really any school shooting that i'm
aware of
the gun that was possessed by the
shooter was possessed illegally
uh and we will make sure that laws are
enforced and those who act illegally
will be held accountable and then really
greatly thanks guys
for george floyd
so
obviously the the texas board of
apartment and paroles just issued their
decision
we go through our legal analysis next
and we'll let you know when we make a
decision great thank you guys so much
for coming
thank you so much thank you all
national guard has been down here
you